after a day of analyzing numbers and
trying to come up with some solid
answers
a new message tonight that there will be
no new results
until tomorrow let's take a look at the
race everyone is talking about
the race for president of course now
specific to nevada we can see
that very small 7 500 vote separation
it was three years ago that it was a two
and a half percentage point win
for hillary clinton and the democrats
this year significantly closer
as we wait for those results what
everyone is doing right now
is waiting for a numbers dump expected
any moment from arizona
we're going to check in with david
charns with more on that and then more
from nevada tomorrow we'll get that data
at 10 a.m
yeah so brian we're looking for those
numbers just
happening right about now as we get that
into our system of course
arizona turning out to be a toss-up
state in this election and those
results that we're waiting are from
maricopa county that's the area
around phoenix 600 000 votes right now
joe biden there looks like he has been
declared the winner by the associated
press 1.4 million votes to president
trump's
1.3 million again looks like vice
president
joe biden taking arizona there again a
lot of talk around that area
around phoenix making up 60 percent of
the
electorate in arizona if my math is
right
if joe biden then takes nevada again
those results expected tomorrow
he would win the presidency we'll keep
you posted brian denise